we are in a situation where numbers are
clearly increasing they're increasing
across
all age groups it's a little bit
different in different areas
in terms of geographies and chris will
speak to that
and this increase in numbers is also
translating
into an increase in hospitalization
which chris will say more about
so there's no doubt we are in a
situation where the numbers are
increasing
what i'd like to do is just remind you
how quickly this can move
so the next slide is not a prediction
but it is a way of thinking about how
quickly this can change
so this is the uk reported cases per day
against time and you can see running
along the bottom there
the number of cases over june july
and august up to roughly 3 000 cases per
day or so
in september middle of september
at the moment we think that the epidemic
is doubling roughly every seven days
it could be a little bit longer maybe a
little bit shorter but let's say roughly
every seven days
if and that's quite a big if but if that
continues
unabated and this grows
doubling every seven days then what you
see of course let's say
there were five thousand today it would
be ten thousand next week twenty
thousand a week after forty thousand the
week after
and you can see that by mid october if
that continued
you would end up with something like 50
000
cases in the middle of october per day
50 000 cases per day would be expected
to lead a month later so the middle of
november say
to 200 plus deaths per day
so this graph which is not a prediction
is simply
showing you how quickly this can move
if the doubling time stays at seven days
and of course the challenge therefore is
to make sure
the doubling time does not stay at seven
days
there are already things in place which
are expected to slow that
and to make sure that we do not enter
into this exponential growth
and end up with the problems that you
would predict as a result of that
that requires speed it requires action
and it requires enough in order to be
able to bring that down